and 100 million people jill the hundred
million people is totally wrong i don't
know where you got that number
the bigger problem that you have private
health care that they're very
simply not true well you said you're
going to socialist yeah you're going to
socialize we're now under general under
my proposal not what you've said right
and it's not what the party is saying
that is simply the party doesn't say
your party wants to go socialist
party is socialist right now i am and
they're gonna dominate you joe you know
that here you
wouldn't be 200 it would be two million
people because you were very late on the
draw
which was heavily president you would
have been much later
mr president you're talking about two
million people you're not graduating as
a moderator
we're going to talk about covet in the
next segment but go ahead
it's on the ballot in the court i think
so on the court well there's nothing
happening there
donald you don't know her well i'll get
rid of the individual
i'm going to give you excuse me i got
rid of the individual mandate which was
a big joke
that is absolutely a big thing that was
the worst part of obamacare
chris yeah that was the worst part of it
let me ask my question i'll ask joe i i
individual mandate was the most
unpopular aspect of obamacare i got rid
of him we will protect
president i'm the moderator of this
debate and i would like you to let me
ask my question and then you can answer
it go ahead
just a tiny fraction this is an open
discussion
sir you'll be happy i'm about to pick up
on one of your points
to ask the vice president private
insurance it is and well
i ask you the question number one
with bernie sanders far left on the
manifesto we call it
manifest you socialize medicine look hey
are you still not gonna
listen to him the fact of the matter is
i beat bernie sanders
not by much i beat him a whole hell of a
lot i'm here i'm here
standing facing you would have left two
days early you would have lost every
price he knows
can you let him finish sir no he doesn't
know how to do that he has
you know right here's the dude sanders
there is no manifesto number please let
him speak mr number two
he just lost the left i um you just lost
the left
you agreed with bernie sanders on a plan
folks absolutely
let the president go ahead sir he has no
plan for health care
of course we do sense please why should
we begin to answer that because the
question is
the question is justice radical left
will you
listen who is on your list joe this is
on youtube
gentlemen i think this is unbelievable
we're not going to give a listen we have
ended this segment president trump did a
phenomenal job we worked with the
governor oh really go take a look
you have to provide that i see pelosi
well he's just shush for a minute and we
did it
wait a minute let me shut you down for a
second joe just for one second
we want to i paid 27 show us your tax
returns uh you'll see it as soon as it's
finished you'll see it
you know if you want to do you paid
millions of dollars millions of dollars
millions of dollars and you'll get to
see it and you'll get to see it
but let me deliver not lower taxes
american people
but in
no we have the highest deficit trade
deficit
my son did nothing wrong at barista i
think he did mr president
[Music]
you've already fired most of them
because they did a good job some people
don't well but here's
with you guys wait a minute you get the
final word well it's hard to get any
word in with this clown
excuse me this hey let me just tell you
no no i'm mr president
the answer to the question is no ukraine
no i sir with a billion dollars
that is absolutely not true gentlemen i
hate to raise my voice but i see it
seems to be
why shouldn't i be different than the
two of you well frankly you've been
doing more interruptions that's all
right but he does plenty
well less than sir there's plenty no
less than you have
let's please continue on they've never
forgotten it you've never seen
no sir it's his two minutes so you did
that when they run through the
town and burn down your stores and kill
people
you say it is he has no law enforcement
that's not true
almost that's not look one law
enforcement group
that came back gentlemen i think i'm
going to i'm going to take back the
moderators
and i want to get to another subject you
have repeatedly criticized i have to
answer his stuff
you have mistaken it lately no you've
been talking to me
statement i'm asking you i would love to
know sir i would love to
you know if you want to switch seats
we're done sir we're moving
your administration tells you the truth
is it has a bad idea can i tell you what
you have no idea either
he said yesterday stupid please stop i
would never
your campaign agreed to both sides would
get two
minute answers uninterrupted well your
side agreed to it
and why don't you observe what your
campaign agreed to as a ground rule okay
sir
you